Israel's president
became the first world leader to
publicly use chagi BT when he gave a
speech partly written by the AI okay
which by the way what a great story for
this year uh what page is that on there
it is okay so Isaac Herzog the president
of Israel became the first world leader
to publicly use the technology Herzog
recorded a video message
for the special opening remarks by at
Cyber Tech Global Tel Aviv 2023 cyber
security conference it's not the
underground plumbing one this is a
different one in front of an audience of
twenty thousand the president then
revealed that the opening section was
written by Chachi wow at least being
honest before concluding that AI is not
going to replace humans the AI written
section began I am truly proud to be the
president of a country that is home to
such a vibrant and Innovative high-tech
industry the President also used Chad
gbt to end the speech with an
inspirational quote let us not forget
that our humanity is what makes us truly
special it's not the machines that will
shape our destiny but rather our hearts
minds and determination
and the Machine and a machine
yeah that is so how do you feel about
that how do you feel about that I mean
for for me I think that AI is definitely
something that we've seen coming and it
doesn't surprise me like obviously I'm
sure the setting of this with it being a
uh a Tech Convention and stuff like that
is very fitting where it's kind of like
a cool gimmick on that end uh but in
terms of if there's a speechwriter doing
something that's drawing up the initial
drafts or it's a an AI or a robot I mean
at the end of the day it's gonna be
edited a human's gonna look at it and
they're going to revise it and change it
and then go from there
maybe not yeah I just think it's
Wikipedia on steroids uh no I had a
somebody sent this to me last night
where they asked uh they asked chat what
about Roger Stone we don't comment on
conspiracy theories wow really so I'm
already banned oh that's hilarious I
mean right right out of the box I mean
I've written you know I've written five
books five Amazon bestsellers two New
York Times bestsellers but my My Views
are too far out there for AI and look at
the flip pad I mean I'm a stand-up I'm a
comedian I'm not crazy well known
somebody in the office was like write me
a joke in the voice of Vincent oshana
and it wrote a joke as me and it was
pretty close I swear to God I don't know
I forgot who it was but I was like oh my
God it's actually scary I mean it's
exciting and scary at the same time but
it's like this is this is just recent
imagine what's what's going to be in
like 10 years and the biggest danger and
thing that's kind of worrisome obviously
what Roger Stone was inclining to there
as well is that the input is we're
setting the limitations of what is
considered conspiracy and we're putting
they're putting that in the machine yeah
the machine isn't necessarily pulling
from it it's just saying what you can or
can't talk about the other thing was
when they were asking about Trump versus
uh Biden on the on the chat gbt and how
it was saying that uh in terms of the
questions they were referring to against
uh Biden was or Trump was no we can't
say that but then with Biden it was
something different so the inputs that
are being put into the machine where now
people are thinking that this is fact or
this is the way it is obviously excuse
the position and that's going to be a
big challenge going forward in terms of
what can we let slide and what can we
not whoever's operating if they're
biased just like you know the Department
of Justice we're [__] basically sorry
for my language or or just like
Wikipedia look you go to my media page
there's so many so many mistakes and
there's some things are just factually
wrong sure I could hire somebody go
ahead and change them you know what
happens they just go back and change
them of course so if you want to know
about me don't bother looking at my
Wikipedia page because almost all of
it's incorrect is that right yeah I mean
you have to trust the internet because
if you Google my high type Patrick but
David Heights yes yes no no wait let's
put Abraham Lincoln yeah I did I did
quote Abraham Lincoln go to uh look at
this Rob was doing his homework right
there if you guys caught that height hi
to go how tall is Patrick with David
you know how tall is Patrick with David
which is people always say Pat
go lower one of them says five seven
you're five seven wow by the way not
only that I'm 154 oh wow that's okay if
you look up my net worth says I'm worth
24 million oh really
I've been Rogers please put Roger Stone
and put mine Rob when you're done with
this 20 million dollars
Rob what would you say mine is what
would you say remind you I have 30 yeah
I'm actually I'm curious to see what
Vincent Lashana net worth would be watch
this Pat
three to five million dollars yeah is
that really what it says okay I
definitely don't have it why are you
keeping all this money yeah because I'm
trying to catch up to the girls they're
paying for lunch I got you so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]